I'm going to play for you a brief sample
of testimony from Kerry Lake's supposed
expert and this was a guy who was going
to help overturn the election or
something and we already looked at how
her lawyers don't seem super competent
and then now here is an expert and it
all goes bad very very quickly you know
[Music]
those are you it would not count it it
would then go to duplication it would be
duplicated
then it would be tabulated is that your
understanding of the elections in
Maricopa County
your technical description is not
possible
I apologize I wasn't attempting to give
a technology I was just saying what
happens
based on your testimony
so you're saying in that scenario that
voter who wanted to vote for Kerry Lake
would never have that vote tabulated is
that your testimony
my testimony is that a shrink to fit
setting would rely at the application
Level which would reside on the EMS
which Mr Garrett just testified since
the print job to the printer therefore
all right you guys understanding this it
can't be accidental as all the employees
that man the EMS are trained
whether it's accidental or inadvertent I
gave the two options please allow me to
ask question I'll allow you to answer
whether it's accidental or inadvertent
if the shrink to fit 19 inch ballot has
to be duplicated once it's duplicated
would it be tabulated
to your understanding
there are two technical
ways that that image would be there none
of the ways you exist is not even
possible that's not responsive to your
honor so what a waste of time this is
what courts are are now being bogged
down with
um here's another moment where the
witness says that Mike pillow has been I
guess paying for some of his travel
everything about this is crazy that has
been hell in Missouri Missouri and was
your travel
from Alabama to Missouri
paid for by someone other than yourself
yes sir and who paid for that
that would I would assume would be
Michael and Dale
all their travel was arranged he asked
me to speak at the event and I spoke
yeah
so
the expert is funded by pillow and
speaking at Mike pillow events uh
disastrous experts disastrous lawyers
Kerry Lake every day is claiming like
they're getting major legal victories in
in these hearings they are not Katie
Hobbs will be the governor of Arizona
mark my words I'm not a betting man but
that's something I would bet on